le principe de l'isolation sensorielle
c'est de mettre tous ses sens au repos
pour que le cerveau ait un minimum de
stimulation et puisse atteindre un état
de conscience intermédiaire se place
dans un caisson dans lequel le noir et
le silence sont complets et qui est
rempli d'une eau saturée en selle de
magnésium dans laquelle le corps flotte
très haut à la surface sans avoir aucun
effort à fournir et pour éviter le
frottement du tissu on enlève le maillot
au début le modèle de caisson
d'isolation sensorielle était
moyennement confortable mais ça s'est
amélioré au fil du temps pour arriver au
modèle qu'on connait aujourd'hui le
principe a continué à être utilisé à
travers les décennies suivantes les
premières minutes sont un peu difficiles
c'est un peu connaître en appisanteur
mais avec les organes génitaux qui
baignent dans le sel j'ai eu des espèces
d'hallucination
visuelles en gros j'ai vu des yeux
flottés dans le noir et les pièces d'une
maison en enhilade comme si je me
déplaçais dans un jeu vidéo en vue
subjective allez savoir pourquoi tout
cas j'ai vécu une expérience très
particulière